[Music]
you look absolutely gorgeous and i am i
am stunned at how tall you are
five ten five eleven in flat feet and
today i'm wearing six inch heels
so you're
i can't do the math right now on the fly
speed five am i taller than you would
like taller than you can i don't think
you're taller than me but i'm also
wearing six inch heels so it could be
receptive but you are a very tall
beautiful woman thank you fantastic
having you on the show thank you you
know i've uh
very
[Laughter]
uh
i'm curious about something uh if you've
noticed this thing in
over the years i've noticed that a lot
of celebrities especially the men are
smaller shrinking they're they're they
get small and do you have this thing
where i never want to i always try and
crouch down when i'm near them and be
like
because
you want to make them to look you want
to make them look good on camera um i i
spent a large part part of my life
slumping on one hip or the other and now
i just stand up and i own it i love
heels
men are getting shorter and it becomes
very awkward when you know being around
shorter people particularly celebrities
when you're asked to take pictures with
people if they're i found if they are
action heroes and uh you know and and
well no i'm not going after
but no no
but if you if they're smaller in real
life than you'd think and you you know
pick them up and go
they don't come back on the show anymore
do you but do you do you find that that
most um celebrities that you meet are so
much smaller
most of them are and then some are
really super tall like jeff goldblum is
super tall yes
what do you think i'm sorry no because
i'm not like how was that wrong i know
what you mean yeah i get very excited i
get very excited when there are other
tall celebrities particularly when
they're tall women i feel like the hug
is equal the picture height is equal the
whole bit okay and you know what i like
about your show as i've been sitting
here for all of two minutes i like the
height of your chairs
yes we try and do that we try and give
people a good sit when they're here do
you mind if i look no no no
these are yes well no i have to tell you
like on my talk show i sit on a purple
couch
and it's had to be uh the feet have to
have had to be altered like three times
to the point now they're about six
inches higher than what the manufacturer
made because when i sit
if the chair is too short i am tucking
my feet underneath me and flipping my
ankles it's just very uncomfortable you
know what i want to do is like a barber
shop i want to have the chair be
adjustable as i speak to the guests
indeed so i can pump them up as i'm
talking about
sliced alone how are you good
my tall is in my legs i have a short
torch i am an incredibly i am a very
long legged gentleman yeah with a tiny
torso
i'm like a little man on a long table
you know it's uh
but i love it i love being tall i and i
get mad when i'm not the tallest woman
in the room really because i've always
heard that women don't like being tall
especially when they're younger they're
self-conscious were you self-conscious
very self-conscious um and but i threw
myself into planning a career planning a
way out of not a way out of jersey
because i love jersey but just the way
out of my town and out of my parents
house right right and now i'm back in
jersey but you know loving being tall
and on my own